I started playing guitar when I was, I think, about eight years old.
I wasn't super dedicated to it for a long time.
When I joined School of Rock like, it kinda made me wanna practice more...
...and I got to start performing and that was a lot more fun...
...than just sitting at home doing nothing.
The first time I performed was at Toby Keith's Bar and Grill.
I only got to play one song.
I got to play "The Immigrant Song" by Led Zeppelin and, I mean, I probably sucked.
I just had a lot of fun with it and enjoyed it a lot.
I sometimes get nervous if I'm playing in front of a bigger crowd.
But normally it doesn't stress me out too much anymore.
And a lot of shows can be really exciting.